à
comme péter walton
bonjour tout le monde nous allons
regarder quelques parties dont le thème
sera la variante guimard de la défense
française donc après les coups de 4,6
des quatre des cinq cas validé deux les
noirs réponde a gagné ses six alors ce
couvent est assez rare
probablement à cause du principe qu'il
ne faut pas bloquer le plan c mais en
pratique du fait de sa rareté et blanc
sont rarement bien préparée contre cette
suite les noirs exerce une pression
directement sur le plan des 4 et après
quatre caves et les gf3 kabli f6 le cinq
cavaliers décède
on arrive à une des grandes positions de
cette variante où les blancs ont un
choix assez important alors d'un point
de vue stratégique du fait que le câble
et noir se trouve en c6 les noirs ne
dispose pas du contre jeu habituel
c'est cette c'est simple la défense
française et ils ont donc deux par
trouver du jeu par le coup de sap f7 f6
nous allons commencer par une partie que
j'ai disputés cet été à l'open de bienne
contre le milan des mages un bloc ou au
6e cool il a préféré cavaliers p3a fouet
2 qui est sans doute plus fréquents
nous reviendrons sur faut deux un petit
peu plus tard donc après cabinet b3 a7
a51 2 à 4 j'ai choisi il faut 7 au lieu
de bissy ce que j'ai déjà employée par
le passé il faut 7 est destiné à éviter
les désagréments liés à cavalier f3 est
simple suivi de damages 5 ou d'objets 4
après le huitième coup des blancs foule
des 5
j'ai joué cavalier à 7 qui est un coup
un peu tordu puisque les cavaliers est
mal placée en à cette aide devra reposer
par la suite mais ce coup permet
de jouer ensuite c'est cette c5
ici les blancs ou 9e coup on va plus
faire cavalier 3 5 qui était mauvais en
raison de ces sept ces six attaquants le
fourbe et 5 et le cabinet à 5
ils ont donc préféré retirer leurs fonds
en d3 et après b6 ou des deux ces cinq
des princes et 5 qui avait les princes
et simple qui avait dépensé 5 mai
français 5 c 4
nous sommes au troisième coup avec une
position très complexe où chaque camp
ont réintégré à ce que l'autre relâche
la tension entre amis en effet après des
cinq des 4 ou des princes et cat les
blancs pourrait utiliser la case de 4
pour leur pièce tandis qu'après ces 4
prend des 5 peut prendre les 5 les noirs
auraient deux jolies pion au centre on
s'est s'inquiété 5 et leurs fous de case
blanche pourrait s'installer en peu 6 où
j'ai 4
dont il s'ensuit différentes manoeuvres
et il nous arrive que nous appelons pour
arriver directement au 28e coup ou la
structure de pions et un peuple est
équilibré mais les noirs dispose de la
paire de fous ici j'avais le choix ou
28e ou entrent souvent en f3 aidé à me
prendre et 2
dans les deux cas les noirs étaient
mieux dans ma finale et il fallait
estimé entre cette note qu'elle était la
suite qui donnait le plus de chances de
gain j'ai choisi il faut prendre trois
parce que j'ai vu que dans les finales
le foot que leur poser
j'avais gagné le pion aux 5 après 29,2
me prends des huit échecs faut prendre
des 8
j'ai pris 3,6 jouer faux g5 celui de fo
f4 il faut prendre 5 et nous aboutissons
à une finale de foot que le reposer ou
et noir ou un clan le plus est certaines
choses bien mais il était difficile
d'estimer si cela sera suffisant
comme cela fait partie d'un autre thème
nous allons revenir au 6e coup et blanc
pour voir des partis un peu plus animée
et revenons au 6e coup les blanches aux
is fuoh 2 fawcett
maintenant sept cavaliers f1 alors ce
coût n'est pas très naturel
mais si les boulangeries petit rock et
noir répondrai soit petit road soit
directement f 7 et 6 et après 8 e prend
1,26 faut prendre 6 les noirs
parviendrait rapidement à jouer au 6 e 5
à libérer complètement leur jeu et
égalise et son problème
ceci est la raison pour laquelle les
blancs préfère sept cavaliers enfin
après petit rock cavaliers ou trois les
noirs jouent finalement le coup et sept
et six pour essayer de libérer leur jeu
praxis car les problèmes 6 après petit
rock falls est des six les noirs peut
envisager de placer leurs cavalières de
4 et essayer d'obtenir du jeu sur
l'album sur les droits parlons ici dans
mon expérience plusieurs parties des vie
en 11e coup j'ai été confronté b2 b3 et
à ses quatre qui est le coût principal
commençons par une b2 b3
donc nous suivons la partie contre le
maître fide claude wagner un
luxembourgeois
je joue et aurait lieu le 4 mai comme
nous le verrons peut-être que b5 b6
était plus judicieux après foulée 2 au
douzième coup b6 c4 j'ai dû jouer
cavalier hausse est ce qu ils raison
pour laquelle je pense que b61 coupe ou
11e coup pardon était plus adaptée en
effet à la place de treize cavaliers 7
le pool tentant fou bessette se heurter
à 71,5 elle prenait 5 avril prend des 5
et maintenant les noirs ne peuvent
récupérer leurs pions par fou prend h 2
parce qu'après câble est proche d'eux
courroye proche d'eux d'emprunter 5 le
clouage fous ces quatre gagnerait la
dame noire
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai dû
jouer treize cavaliers de 7 pour
défendre le pion des saintes
maintenant le meilleur et c'est pour les
blancs pour obtenir davantage était de
jouer cavalier le 5 ans 14e coup celui
de f2 f3 chassons les cavaliers ou 4 à
la place mon adversaire a préféré dame
c2 et après fou mais cette cave à 2,5
j'ai joué fou prend 1,5 des points 5 et
d4 ouvrant la diagonale du fou 17 qui va
l'emmener ensuite vers le pion g2 et
même petit rock ou des blancs
ce thème l'ouverture de la grande
diagonale apparaîtra dans d'autres
parties de cette variante est en général
de manière très efficace pour les noirs
après dix-sept toral bien j'ai joué le
sacrifice de dame des prés de trois
tours prend dix huit le tour à apprendre
des 8 et maintenant la menace tour d2
fait que les noirs sont assurés de
pouvoir prendre encore le pion aux deux
à partir de ce moment il n'y a déjà plus
de défense pour les blancs que mon
adversaire a choisi 19 faut des trois
épreuves deux échecs pour h1y six
cavaliers f5 était très fort c'est le
coup que j'ai choisi parce que sur 21
faut prendre le 4k volume de 3 faut
prendre cet échec
suite menouar gagner
pour cela pour cette raison mon
adversaire a joué 21 pouces et un
empêchement cavaliers de 3 ou de suivi
tour des quatre fois f4 cavaliers h4
visant le plan g2 et après le retour
flou et 3g bédié en jouant tout
reprendre les trois dames prend des
droits qui avait laissé cinq attaquants
la dame des trois révélations faux
projet de vote
donc c'est ensuite c'est ainsi que s'est
conclue cette partie revenons au 11e
coup et au choix un blanc le plus
fréquent 11
c'est de ces quatre jeux poussée de ses
4 comporte une menace positionnelle c4
c5 qui gagnerait de l'espace et après le
coup fluide et six f4 les blancs
poursuivre et par cavalier ces deux pour
échanger les foudres cases noires
suivies de troubles et 5 qui leur
assurerait le contrôle de la case aux 5
en conséquence les noirs doivent
empêcher c4 c5 et il joue bessette b6
après douze baies 3
faux bessette deux de mes parties de les
berges
maxime vachier lagrave avait choisi
s'éprend des cinq qui est peut-être plus
judicieux que le plus fréquent 13 four
et 2 après apprend des cinq cavaliers f5
qu'avait lieu le cat cave les prends
di6dent prendrait six fours les deux
cavaliers d'élite nocerino 16e coup de
la partie qui m'a opposé à l'oca maxime
aux championnats de france d'aix les
bains en 2007
je pensais avoir une position
satisfaisante et poursuivre par cavalier
ou six f4 combiné peut-être à la poussée
et c'est cette c5
mais maxime mieux
à mieux juger cette position est mieux
estimer les complications et finalement
après 17 qui a valu aux cinq qui a eu
lieu six f2 f3 kabylie 4 les cinq tours
siens ces cinq vins des princes et 5b
prince et 5
cette position que j'estimais incertaine
s'est révélé meilleur pour les blancs le
choix le plus fréquent et 13 fauves et 2
plutôt que c'est prendre les 5 que
maxime a joué et après au f4 j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire quelques jolies
parties la première s'est poursuivie par
14 tours siens un coup un peu bizarre
puisque le tour va volontairement dans
l'emploi il faut être quatre après
cavale de quatre fous des 3 15 cavaliers
beckham
les noirs ont déjà une partie très
confortable et des bonnes chances
d'attac sur le droit le coup cavalli c6
b4 instaure la menace de jouer des
princes et 4 à tout moment et d'ouvrir
le débat noble du fou bessette qui comme
nous l'avons déjà vu van lorgner sur les
droits blanche
mon adversaire le est mis en croix
entame a joué à ce moment 16 faut bien
et après cavaliers g5 qu'avait lieu le 5
dépensé 4 il a commis la gaffe des
princes et cat
un coût qui paraissait pourtant normal
et après vous prend 1,5 des points 5
les noirs disposés de dix neuf cavaliers
trois échecs avec une attaque déjà
décisive la suite de la partie et 20
crachin sûr je prends un f3 l'énorme
poursuivi par dame j'ai cinq échecs
suivi de fou prend 9 3 et les blancs ont
réduit launay la dame pour éviter le mat
après 3 h 1 j'ai joué des matches 4 mais
le son d'un proche de menthe h2 h3 torah
des huit dames et 3 et maintenant la
partie s'est conclue par cavalier des
deux d'un premier cas d'un prince trois
chèques angers un cavalière trois
chèques et les blancs ont abandonné
puisque le match était imparable
en conclusion pour dans cette variante
il faut noter que les blondes faire très
attention au moment où les les noirs
peuvent libérer la grande diagonale et
activer leur fougue et cents
pour cette raison le choix de maxime 13
c'est prendre des 5e prendrait
s'inquiéter son objet une bonne idée
puisque après les noirs ne dispose plus
du coût des princes et cap
mais les blancs du bit